(smooth music)
- What's up guys?
Michael here to talk about
"South Park", wait what was that?
Sure.
Sorry, we're actually talking about war.
The past few weeks, the
media's been saturated
with the latest upsetting updates
about Russia's attack on Ukraine.
And because we have beating hearts,
the whole situation has
had us pretty disturbed.
It's not that we're strangers
to hearing about armed
conflict in the news.
Between civil wars, long-term
violent unrest over territory,
and the occasional undeclared American war
that lasts a goddamn lifetime,
it can start to feel like
state sanctioned violence
is perpetual, contractable,
and somewhat ubiquitous.
But as we watch the most surprising
and depressing events of 2022 play out
we've been wondering,
what is the point of war?
Why do human beings always
seem to be waging it?
Is it natural?
And yes of course, what is it good for?
("War" by Edwin Star plays)
♪ Absolutely nothin' ♪
So join us on this very
lighthearted journey
into the deeply violent depths of mankind
in this Wisecrack Edition on war.
Why?
The answer to the question why war
might at first seem pretty obvious.
The way most people explain
humanities propensity for war
is that it's inevitable, it's
natural, it just kind of is.
In fact if we had the production budget
to man on the street to
question is war natural,
we're pretty sure that one
we'd overwhelmingly hear yes,
and two I'd probably get beaten
up on Hollywood Boulevard.
Anyway that gut reaction has some
scientific and philosophical credence.
Most obviously there's the
classic philosophical screen
from one Thomas Hobbes
who argued that life is
nasty, brutish, and short,
and he didn't mean nasty in a good way.
Or as the poet Nas once said.
("Life's a Bitch" by Nas playing)
♪ Life's a (beep) and then you die ♪
Other proponents of this view
that violence amongst
mankind just kinda happens
would include the likes of William James
and Sigmund Freud.
And plenty of anthropological scholarship
bolsters this belief, with
fossilized human bodies
showing evidence of man on man violence.
Since the 1960's anthropologists
have used the savanna savanna
as a surrogate for early humans
and found that they appear
to really like hitting each other.
Famously a study of the Yanomamö people,
one of the last few remaining
truly hunter-gatherer tribes
conducted by controversial
anthropologist Napoleon Chagnon,
found that men who
committed multiple murders
had more reproductive success,
I-E acquired more wives
than those who didn't.
He used these findings
to argue that violence
is a desirable evolutionary
trait in male humans,
which yeah that tracks
with every James Bond movie I've seen.
However many scholars push
back on this idea altogether.
Take the Yanomamö example.
For starters, it's been alleged
that much of the violence Chagnon observed
amongst the Yanomamö was
actually caused by Chagnon
who handed out machetes and axes
to encourage the tribe members
to participate in his study.
What's more, anthropologist
Douglas Fry's analysis
of Chagnon's data finds that
the men who committed murders
were on average 10 full years
older than the peaceful ones,
giving them way more
opportunity to land a few wives.
This is obviously an isolated example,
but it speaks to a much bigger
epistemological problem,
that is a problem with the
way we acquire knowledge.
According to Fry,
western scholars studying
ancient hunter-gatherer cultures
tend to suffer from a
sort of confirmation bias.
Because we live in a world torn up by war
where violence is just
part of the landscape,
it's easy for folks
studying ancient humans
to find evidence of war everywhere.
Skeletons of cavemen
that show damage to the skull for instance
were typically interpreted to be evidence
that one guy clubbed
the other guy to death,
thus humans are naturally violent.
But Fry argues that upon closer inspection
some cases like these have
been found to merely indicate
that the ancient human
was attacked by animals,
or that their skeleton had gone through
run of the mill archeological decay.
Or take the 9,000 year
old walls of Jericho,
commonly thought of as the first
archeological evidence of war,
which have also caused some
serious scholarly disagreement.
Some experts now believe
that the walls were built
to protect the city against flooding
rather than against hostile neighbors.
In his book "Beyond War"
Fry makes a compelling case
that for the majority of our existence
war has actually been extremely rare.
He notes that although
the violence of homicide,
feud, and war grab our attention,
an examination of cross-cultural data
reveals that people
usually deal with conflicts
without using any violence at all.
While violence between
individuals, usually male,
seems to have always been around,
Fry argues that the unmitigated killing
between two or more groups
that is necessary to
constitute capital W war
is remarkably absent from
most of human history.
Scholar John Gowdy adds
that judging from historical
accounts of hunter-gatherers
for most of the time humans
have been on the planet
we have lived in relative harmony
with the natural world
and with each other.
Our minds and cultures evolved
under these conditions.
Evidence suggests that war emerged
only when human social
order became more complex,
adopting among other things
hierarchy's and horses.
What's more, large scale war
appears to have only existed
for less than 2,000 years.
A mere drop in the bucket for homosapiens.
Fry even argues that human
beings have successfully evolved
precisely because
evolution favors restraint
and limited interpersonal aggression.
In fact, it's one of our strengths.
Human beings are creative
and adaptive enough
to find non-violent solutions to problems,
such as soliciting a friendly
mediator, talking things out,
or my favorite tactic, simply
running the (beep) away
from the angry guy holding the club.
Now the idea that human beings
are naturally prone towards
peace is of course contested.
But at the very least,
fry's account throws a
serious shade of doubt
on the assumption that cavemen
were prone to group violence,
and that human beings
are basically chimpanzees
with less facial hair.
And many scholars agree
with Fry's contention
that most human societies existed
largely in a state of peace and abundance.
You may be wondering why we're talking
about ancient hunter-gatherers
in our purported attempt
to understand modern war,
but it's really important
that we not take the reality
of warfare for granted.
That's because assuming that humanity
is naturally war happy
necessarily changes the way we
react to and think about war.
As Fry explains,
naturalizing war creates an unfortunate
self fulfilling prophecy.
If war is natural,
then there is little point
in trying to prevent,
reduce, or abolish it.
It's like the macro version
of the depressing statistic
that people with a gun in their house
are more likely to die of homicide.
And we'd argue that the assumption
that war amongst humans is natural
underpins a lot of the narratives
we tell ourselves about ourselves.
These days it's easy to
feel like war is inevitable.
Scholar James Hillman writes,
during the 5,600 years of written history
14,600 wars have been recorded,
two or three wars each
year of human history.
That's pretty (beep) staggering.
But if you, like us,
have a strong distaste for
organized human violence,
it's worth looking to peaceful societies
no matter how differently
they might be structured
from our own.
What makes indiscriminate violence
between two or more
groups of people so rare
until relatively recently?
Arguably the lack of fixed group identity
plays a pretty big role.
See in ancient hunter-gatherer societies
if you belonged to one band of people
and got in a big fight
with your bunk mate,
you would often simply leave that band
and join a different one.
And because lineage was frequently tracked
both matrilineally and patriarch-ally
you would have kin in multiple tribes,
so you had friendly options.
What's more, the overlapping flux
of the state of group membership
made violence between
groups less likely overall.
As Fry explains about the
Aboriginal people of Australia,
band membership was
neither closed nor static.
Individuals and families
shifted band residence
over both the short-term
and the long-term.
Virtually every person
had relatives and contacts
in other groups.
These overlapping social
and kinship networks
that spanned the flexible bands
served to damp inter group hostility.
The idea of floating
between a network of groups
at first blush might be
hard for us to relate to.
Most of us forge our identity
largely based on the groups
we permanently belong to,
like bald dudes with hearts of gold
and slightly raised cholesterol.
And often we identify primarily
by our country of origin.
As scholar Benedict
Anderson wrote back in 1873,
nation-ness is the most
universally legitimate value
in the political life of our time.
But it's important to note
that the idea of national
identity is a relatively new one
if you take the grand span of
human history into account.
Some scholars note that medieval elites
may have had a national consciousness
thanks in part to the
influence of the church,
this didn't really reach the masses
and become modern nationalism
until the eighteenth century
when thanks to enlightenment
and romantic thinking,
nationalism became what
scholar John Hutchinson calls
a surrogate religion.
Whereas previously
borders have been porous,
the concept of a unified nation
carried a greater sense of solidarity
when it emerged in
Europe around this time.
Anderson attributes the
rise of European nationalism
in the late 1700's to three things.
First the fall of Latin
as Europe's universal religious language,
accompanied by the rise
of national dialects.
Second the death of the divine monarch
in the cultural imagination,
which (woman screams) required now
precariously positioned rulers
to seek out other forms of legitimacy.
And lastly the emergence of
the mass produced newspaper,
which united countrymen in a
shared experience in worldview.
These factors coalesce
to start building more
robust national identities.
Now of course there was war
before there were modern nations.
Ancient empires didn't form
out of pure fondness for their leaders.
And there were outliers of
large scale long-term warfare
long before the eighteenth century,
such as the hundred years
war which ended in 1453.
See England and France
used it to figure out
who gets to own and be France.
Obviously a young Chicago
woman named Emily Cooper
who is in Paris,
'cause we're talking
about "Emily in Paris".
But if anything, this was a
precursor of things to come.
The people involved were
starting to be attuned
to large collective identities
that would solidify and
strengthen in future centuries.
Anderson refers to a nation
as an imagined political community,
because a person in any given country
could never possibly know
all of their fellow community members.
Creating a nation Anderson explains,
also forges a deep horizontal comrade-ship
that is shared amongst its people.
But according to him,
this sense of camaraderie
is not without potential consequence.
He contends that ultimately
it is this fraternity
that makes it possible
over the past two centuries,
for so many millions of
people, not so much to kill,
as willingly to die for
such limited imaginings.
That is perhaps to say
that without our deep national allegiances
it wouldn't be possible
to convince so many people to
go to war in the first place.
To be clear, Anderson's
views are not unopposed.
And some scholars think the connection
between nationalism and
war can be overstated.
But interestingly enough
others argue that there's
also a reciprocal relationship
between war and nationalism.
Scholar John Hutchinson argues
that wars and their aftermath
only further bolster national identities.
That is to say, our nations
might bring us to war
but war also brings us
closer to our nations.
Or as scholar Charles Tilly says,
war made the state and the state made war.
Now obviously there's nothing wrong
with being proud of your country of origin
or with having your
identity deeply tied to it.
But Fry's research does
substantiate Anderson's argument.
He found pretty conclusively
that as society trended away
from loose hierarchy free collectives
and towards governed
organized nation states,
war became far more
likely across the board.
That's not exactly surprising.
You can't assemble an army
out of a small band of
loosely connected people,
but you can destroy the
one ring to rule them all.
Militarism necessarily relies
on butt loads of folks
willing to risk their lives
for something bigger,
and that something is very often a nation.
And that deeply ingrained
sense of national pride
facilitates the kinds of
wars our ancient ancestors
never would've thought to
wage in the first place.
Of course you need more
than just a complex society
to wage a war, and not
all complex societies do.
Fry determined back in 2006
that 20 countries in recent history
have gone at least 100
years without a war.
You need one more all important thing
and it's not a literal enemy.
As Hillman writes in his book,
"A Terrible Love of War",
all along we are speaking
of the idea of an enemy,
a phantom enemy.
It is not the enemy
that is essential to war
and that forces war upon
us, but the imagination.
Imagination is the driving force.
The way we imagine our enemies then
rather than any reality
based rage or hatred,
is often the true instigator of war.
We don't talk a lot about
the nature of war today,
which shows the organized battle fields
of say the Civil War
where reporters could safely
observe from the sidelines,
but targeted air strikes
that typically dig into
civilian territory.
And specifically we don't often discuss
how war is actually more
dangerous for regular folks
than ever before.
As reporter Caroline Nordstrom notes,
approximately 90 percent of casualties
in modern warfare are civilians.
The enemy is no longer enlisted soldiers
fulfilling duties in the trenches
as we've seen all too glaringly
in the coverage of Ukraine,
as well as in decades
of American air strikes
in the middle East, just to name a few.
Today it's hard to imagine a war
that doesn't involve civilian casualties.
And this can feel pretty
depressing when you're someone
with functionally no
control over geopolitics.
Fry is ever the optimist.
He notes that humans
have survived for so long
precisely because we're
highly inventive and adaptive.
After all, we largely went from living
in tiny bands of foragers
to industrialized cities
in the evolutionary blink of an eye.
And he argues that with
enough political will
we could use that adaptiveness
to construct a world without wars.
And while that may sound a bit sentimental
we thought we owed you at
least one uplifting thought.
So what do you guys think?
Is war just the inevitable
result of modern civilization?
Would we be better off if
society had never come up
with alternatives to
hunting and gathering?
Let us know in the comments.
Huge thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
Be sure to check out our new Patreon page,
we're dropping some new exclusive content.
Tap that subscribe button gently
like the peaceful homosapien you are.
And don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)